el programa de acción diferida para los
llegados en la infancia llamado daca
cumplió 10 años de su creación mientras
más de 600 mil beneficiados mantienen la
ilusión de una solución migratoria
permanente y millones más quisieran al
menos obtener este amparo temporal el 15
de junio del año 2002 el entonces
presidente barack obama estableció el
programa que protege de la deportación y
otorga permisos de trabajo renovables
cada dos años a estos inmigrantes que
llegaron al país de forma irregular
siendo unos niños daca nació como una
respuesta provisional a la incapacidad
del congreso estadounidense para dar una
solución permanente a estas personas los
beneficiarios de daca aportan casi 42
mil millones de dólares anuales a la
economía estadounidense sin embargo el
senado no ha aprobado una ley que
proteja a los llamados soñadores
actualmente una corte de apelaciones
podría eliminar estas protecciones si no
se descarta la posibilidad de que esta
batalla legal acabe en la corte suprema
de eeuu quiere salvar entonces entonces
a nuestra primera invitada al día
angélica guzmán ella es beneficiaria de
daca y también organizadora en el
movimiento de derechos de inmigrantes
gracias angélica por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 le
pregunto por supuesto cuál es la
situación de los llamados soñadores a 10
años de este programa daca
bueno pues nuestra situación es muy
incierta
te lo digo tenemos una
una cita con la corte de apelaciones en
julio 6 que podría acabar el programa
esto ha traído mucha ansiedad y pues han
sido diez años de lucha han sido diez
años de
mostrarnos en las calles de estar en
este movimiento y de inacción por las
administraciones sabemos que es posible
que se nos de protecciones solamente
es cosa de que la administración del
presidente bailen y tome la decisión
también como el congreso
angélica le pregunto porque hasta el
momento ya son diez años y todavía no se
ha hecho nada para para ser permanente
este programa de protección no cuál es
el palo en la rueda digamos de que
tienen ustedes y cómo se sienten además
bueno nosotros sabemos que el problema
hasta ahora ha sido el congreso la
ignacion del congreso el partido
republicano no no ha querido trabajar
partido demócrata para pasar una
solución permanente y ahorita se
controla el congreso
por el partido demócrata y aún así el
partido republicano ha bloqueado
cualquier intento de pasar algo alguna
solución lo hemos visto con el paquete
de bilbao werder que no fue pasado que
podría haber tenido una protección para
nosotros los dreamers y para muchas más
personas por supuesto que esto nos hace
sentir muy muy
muy ansiosos y muy molestos porque
nosotros los que trabajamos en este
movimiento y todas las personas que nos
vemos involucradas hemos trabajado para
que esta administración fuera elegida
entonces lo hicimos en el fondo de las
promesas que nos hicieron
y no ha hecho nada digamos hasta
entonces el gobierno del presidente yo
bailén para arreglar su situación
digamos cómo se sienten con esto y
además le quiero preguntar qué tan lejos
está en eeuu para realmente lograr una
reforma integral en materia de migración
sí bueno el gobierno del presidente
turbay de nada han hecho muchos intentos
es cuestión y eso es parte del sistema
político en los eeuu se necesitan dos
partidos y en este caso no se tienen los
60 votos
también el gobierno del presidente by de
lo que podría hacer es
sobrepasar
a órdenes ejecutivas en vez de esperarse
al congreso lo que nosotros sabemos es
que él no quiere hacer eso porque las
órdenes ejecutivas son solamente se
puede decir pueden ser temporales
por eso eso nos hace sentir muy
frustrados
han sido diez años de miedo han sido de
diez años de constante lucha y la lucha
va a seguir el jugarán julio 6 tenemos
una ciudad con la corte de apelaciones
como le digo nos tiene muy ansiosos nos
tienen muy asustados pero seguimos
reclamando le a esta administración que
tome las medidas necesarias para
protegernos a todos los dreamers ya toda
la comunidad indocumentada aunque lejos
estamos de conseguir esto es solamente
cosa de que el congreso se ponga de
acuerdo en tener los suficientes votos o
que el partido demócrata se ponga de
acuerdo en sobrepasar ese bloqueo de los
60 votos para pasar una legislación de
inmigración angélica que cree que pueda
pasar cuando este caso llegue a la corte
de apelaciones digamos que fue en el
2018 cuando el entonces presidente
donald trump canceló este programa
además fue declarado ilegal por un juez
de texas en el año 2021 y hasta ahora
entonces se va a la organización by de
la administración de iovine después
llegó esto a la corte de apelaciones de
la que estamos hablando la que tiene que
decidir que pudiera pasar cuáles son los
escenarios ustedes manejan digamos
bueno nosotros siempre manejamos el
mejor y el peor escenario en el peor
escenario estamos viendo a la actividad
de corte que queda que es ilegal y que
acabe con este programa el mejor
escenario sería que lo declarara legal y
que nos deje continuar con las nuevas
aplicaciones y existentes aplicaciones
de daca que incluiría a muchas personas
que no entraron en el programa cuando
fue puesto
en la peor situación estamos pensando en
lo que puede hacer el gobierno
parar
a ser más suave en la finalización de
daca obviamente la corte de apelaciones
es tradicional y
va a ser un poco difícil que nos dé esa
reacción positiva pero estamos
preparados para lidiar con un final acá
y también para lidiar con una
continuación de daca digamos si si llega
el fin de daca que planean hacer ustedes
además quiero quiero preguntarle si
podría entonces la corte suprema-
pronunciarse en contra de acá teniendo
en cuenta que tiene mayoría conservadora
sí bueno en caso de que acá finalice
nosotros planeamos acciones
con nuestros representantes con el
gobierno en washington y también
nosotros planeamos llevar esto hasta la
corte suprema de nuevo si usted tiene
razón que la corte suprema- ahorita
tiene una mayoría está conservativa
conservadora pero nosotros creemos que
tenemos un buen estándar para el caso de
la legalidad de daca a muchos
muchos expertos legales ya han dicho que
daca es legal entonces nosotros estamos
preparados para pelear esto hasta las
últimas consecuencias